[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle veut pas se fermer
voilà pourquoi la voyais arriver on va
finir par y arriver résume la merci
bonjour je vois que pratiquement tous
ceux qui sont ici sont nés dans une
dictature
je vous rassure moi aussi pourtant je
suis né dans une clinique non loin d'ici
avenue de la liberté
pourtant j'ai toujours habité la même
maison quartier de la rue de la
démocratie liberté et démocratie
voici deux mots qui ont toujours été
présents tout au long de mon parcours
deux mots qui ne m'ont jamais quitté et
dieu seul sait à quel point je me suis
attaché
deux points avec lesquels on peut
combattre la halle de la justice là où
elle se trouve
là on la cache à 10-11 ans je regarde un
film en famille un film français
extraits du livre de gilles perrault le
pull-over rouge
il raconte l'histoire d'un procès
trouble où l'unique accusé christian
ranucci passe à la ve après quelques
heures d'interrogatoire au bout duquel
il reconnaît le meurtre d'une fillette
qui avaient mon âge à l'époque
un procès troubles des irrégularités et
pourtant il est condamné à mort le
président valéry giscard d'estaing lui
refusa la grâce il fut exécuté ce procès
qui avait vu plusieurs il a été entachée
d'irrégularités et souvent la plaidoirie
de son avocat magnifique plaidoirie
magistralement mise en scène par cette
fiction qui a fait du combat contre la
peine de mort l'argument principal pour
ceux qui demandaient que par exemple
principalement l'erreur judiciaire
l'erreur judiciaire a été mise en scène
dans cette danse dans ce film et ç'a
permis
petit à petit à ce que les consciences
change en france
christian ranucci a été le dernier
français guillotiné grâce à l'initiative
d'un avocat hors norme
robert badinter qui grâce à ses
plaidoiries
mais également à sa présence a fait
changer les choses je donc je fus donc
fasciné par cet homme robert badinter
qui tout au long de son parcours a fait
en sorte à croire en une seule idée et a
réussi à changer les choses je fus donc
fasciné par ce talent et j'ai essayé moi
même est ce que un jour je prends et je
combats les injustices autant que je
peux
à 20 ans je fais moi-même victime d'une
injustice c'est la première fois que je
vais en parler j'ai été arrêté suite à
une rixe à laquelle je n'ai pas
participé
j'ai donc vu ce qui s'est passé dans les
commissariats
j'ai vu les humiliations j'ai vu les
maltraitances j'ai vu l'injustice
partout je fut libéré après cinq longs
jours grâce à la plaidoirie d'un avocat
dont les mots résonnent encore dans mes
oreilles
cet avocat devient mon maître de stage
quand je m'inscris au barreau dix ans
plus tard c'est terrible expérience m'a
conforté dans mon choix
combattre les injustices avocat je
soutiens tout de suite les jeunes du
village
des stats ce qu'on appelle les
viragistes une jeunesse incomprise une
jeunesse révoltée
face à un état policier
un état policier qui continue jusqu'à
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui regardez par
exemple cette image d'il ya une dizaine
de jours
rien ne justifié cette violence pourtant
ils sont toujours là et ils ont toujours
les mêmes pratiques
tout de suite après viennent les procès
qui sont qui qui ont été multipliés sous
les gouvernements issus de des premières
élections libres dans le pays des procès
contre la liberté d'expression
alors il ya eu la sphère persepolis par
exemple parce que une chaîne avait
diffusé un film que certains avaient
jugé comme atteinte au sacré nous sommes
montés au créneau pour défendre la
liberté d'expression encore une fois
personnellement j'ai eu à connaître les
grands procès politique
c'était mon premier procès et j'ai pu
renouer contact avec les meilleurs
avocats de tunisie
les ténors du barreau et ses meilleurs
représentants militants tels que chokri
belaid et faouzi ben mrad c'était pour
nous et on a gagné pratiquement tous ses
procès il y en a eu plein il y en a eu
wild 15 klaibi bidji m 2 m6 et des
rappeurs et ils ont tous été condamnés à
de la prison ferme deux ans pour 8 et le
15 par exemple pour une chanson qui lie
bidji 21 mois et ses amis l'un fait men
etc
il y a eu à l'occasion de ce procès là
quelque chose de nouveau
la mobilisation des des jeunes des
quartiers difficiles qui étaient avec
nous devant les tribunaux dans les
réseaux sociaux et puis on a eu des
procès contre des blogueurs contre des
journalistes des artistes aziz amami par
exemple aussi ses vélib en local et on a
eu à défendre des dizaines de citoyens
connus et landa parmi les cent vingt
mille tunisiens qui ont été condamnés
conformément à la loi 52 la loi 52 unis
le simple consommateur de cannabis à un
an de prison ferme d'une peine d'amendé
de 1000 à 3000 dinars mais d'une peine
d'emprisonnement pouvant aller
danon à cinq ans de prison ferme face à
cette injustice une loi injuste
qui ne donne pas au juge le pouvoir
d'apprécier ce qui faisait que les
peines minimales étaient d'un an de
prison ferme et mille dinars d'amendé
nous avons constitué un collectif
composé d'avocats de toxicologues de
deux médecins spécialistes de
journalistes etc
mais ce qui a alimenté cette initiative
citoyenne c'était les familles des
victimes et bien sûr les deux ex détenus
et clc lille 5 ans 2 est un concept
ouvert à tous tout le monde pouvait
adhérer et donc on est on a gagné une
première bataille à partir du moment que
cette initiative est devenu c'est à dire
une initiative où tout le monde pouvait
venir et bien sûr c'était surtout les
familles des victimes
il fallait pour nous briser les tabous
permettre à ces victimes de parler et de
connaître leurs visages aussi et
pourtant par rapport à ça nous avons lu
ce qui nous confronter directement
c'étaient les politiques ne voulait pas
qu'on abroge la loi sans compte donc il
fallait briser les tabous il fallait
aussi leur donner un visage les
humaniser et quand on humanise un
quelqu'un qui en prison les tunisiens ne
savent pas que ça touche tout le monde
donc c'est venu petit à petit
donc voilà deux jeunes par exemple 18
ans d'un gouvernorats de l'intérieur de
jeunes de celle yens 18 ans qu'elle est
passé leur bac cette année selon leurs
professeurs ils allaient réussir il
avait le bon niveau il préparer les
examens etc
ils sont sortis dimanche parmi avec des
amis et cetera elles se font condamné à
un an de prison ferme à cause d'un joint
donc c'était un collectif ouvert et un
moment donné face au conservatisme qui
était partout pas uniquement chez les
politiques
mais dans toute la société tunisienne un
blocage sur ce sujet là et puis
j'apprends en me connectant sur des
réseaux sociaux quinze jours la liste va
recevoir un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle des plus importants
c'était donc fin c'était pendant la fin
de la campagne électorale
ce journaliste a mis d'ailleurs c'est
celui qui m'a présenté m'a dit qu'à tous
qui est là il est partout match 4 pose
une question à ce candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il lui dit si vous êtes
élu président de la république
allez-vous réformer la loi 52 et contre
toute attente le candidat beji caïd
sebsi 125
dans un plaidoyer impeccable on ne
demandait pas plus il s'engageait à
réformer la loi 52 dks il est élu
président de la république
quelques semaines après il devient
depuis nous ne l'avons plus lâchait un
matraquage presque naturel cette
opérette
les médias sont donné à coeur joie pour
rappeler cette promesse électorale
nous nous faisons ça tous les jours a
rappelé cette promesse électorale
jusqu'à ce que les politiques à chaque
arrestation à chaque condamnation était
montrée du doigt comme coupable de la
situation
face à ça nous continuons tout le joue
tous les jours le combat il fallait
mobilier pour nous mobiliser tout le
monde les journalistes les médias les
bien sûr les loges et historique qui
d'ailleurs quelques unes était très
réticente au départ
combien de fois ai-je entendu cette
phrase toutes les lois seront modifiés
sauf la loi 52
on ne touchera pas aux intérêts de
certaines professions
la mobilisation continue et toujours
avec ces visages pour montrer à tout le
monde pour les humaniser encore en foire
pour faire évoluer les mentalités en
faisait des sit in on n'était pas
souvent nombreux on organisait des
débats publics
on est on allé dans les conférences
chaque occasion pour nous pour me
remettre dans l'actualité ce sujet là
étaient bons à prendre
on a réuni les bonnes volontés
tout ce qui pouvait donner de l'énergie
à ces situations là et puis encouragé
les partis politiques parmi lesquels ces
jeunes d'un parti de gauche pour aussi
demandé l'abrogation de la loi 52
on a aussi essayé de faire en sorte que
l'on touche à toutes les catégories
sociales à tous les arches comme cette
dame qu'elle nous a ouvert ce encore
pour participer à la campagne de
sensibilisation pour la libération de
trois artistes
cette magnifique dames et ma mère
[Applaudissements]
elle est là quelque part je la vois pas
mais je pense que ça me fait plaisir de
se faire applaudir
voilà et un jour d'après toutes les
tout le monde nous disait que c'était
pas possible
l'assemblée des représentants du peuple
il y a moins de trois semaines adopter
une loi modifiant la loi 52
c'était merci donc une loi pour une
avancée considérable parce qu'elle
permettra au juge d'apprécier au cas par
cas drg les peines requises contre les
consommateurs de drogue
donc si vous voyez cette image
ce n'est pas moi qui ai fait cette loi
mais j'ai participé à ce que le débat
avance tous les jours je les fais autant
que je pouvais pourquoi parce que c'est
de ses venues de loin en revenant j'ai
pour moi c'est un combat que je peux
même que je pouvait mener et finalement
on l'a gagné même si la bataille
continue parce que ce n'est pas la
meilleure loire mais en tout cas cette
loi permettra de d'éviter la descente
est né à des milliers de jeunes de
connaître la peine de connaître la case
prison
finalement l'injustice contrairement à
la justice n'est pas un concept mais un
ressenti et le ressenti est plus fort
que l'idée alors que alors que la
justice alors que la justice n'est pas
un alors que l'injustice peut trouver
ses moyens chaque fois qu on donne de
nous la détermination dont vous de la
société civile a permis à ce que le
gouvernement recule
les politiques reculent
et adopte une nouvelle loi donc on
s'était dit que si on avait gagné cette
bataille
on pouvait gagner aussi les autres
batailles dont il ya beaucoup de lois en
tunisie qui lit des lois rétrogrades qui
ne sont pas de notre époque et qu'il
faut bien sûr continuer ce combat juste
après ça donc cette loi est ronde et
entré en vigueur il ya quatre jours deux
jours après un tribunal de tunis quand
la personne comparé à comparer il fut
libéré à la première comparution et donc
les condamnations peuvent maintenant
aujourd'hui le plus être à de la prison
ferme
mais avec une amende ou relation avec
lui la menthe ou avec de la prison avec
sursis donc il fallait encore bouger
bouger et penser qu'à un moment donné on
pouvait gagner
en tout cas la détermination donc vous
savez évoluer
on a fait évoluer les mentalités pas
uniquement les mentalités mais on essaie
aussi de faire gagner la confiance des
gens même ceux qui étaient contre
parce qu' il fallait ratisser large
c'est joli donc si on a pu faire ça on
peut faire pour les autres lois et moi
je demande à chaque fois à chaque fois
c'est à dire à chaque fois de rencontrer
les gens de dire que c'est possible de
continuer et de ne pas briser des vies
et y en a eu des vies brisées
on a eu plein on a celui qui est rentré
pour un an qui a des qui trouvent des
condamnations à l'intérieur même d'une
prison c'est-à-dire avec l'élite avec
les fonctionnaires de de la pression
donc
on l'a brisé les tabous on a fait
évoluer les mentalités
une loi plutôt bonne une avancée
considérable
on a essayé car on n'a jamais perdu
espoir
le changement est possible s'ils auront
des sites demain commence dès maintenant
si vous pouvez nous aider à ce que à
chaque fois combattre les injustices on
sera toujours avec vous merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]